since the dawn of man
the majestic Asian elephant has been
worshipped as a god-like symbol of
strength and wisdom with the largest
brains of all land animals they are
highly intelligent and exhibit a wide
range of sophisticated behavior
including learning language and tool use
elephants Maximus is the biggest mammal
in the lab weighing a massive seven tons
more than three full-sized cars it is
also the strongest able to carry the
weight of a hundred men and a fruit even
the tallest trees it is easy to
understand why these beasts have no
natural predators
deployed by Alexander the Great like a
heavy tank a charging elephant becomes
unstoppable at 20 miles per hour with
its spear like tusks formidable trunk
and crushing limbs
the elephant's natural weapons give it
the destructive power of a true war
machine the elephant remains a force to
be reckoned with to ride one you must be
bold to challenge one you must be
suicidal fun fact
elephants crave the taste of human blood
and when it comes to vengeance and
elephant never forgets
[Applause]
pre-order now for a free upgrade to the
limited edition includes three extra
story missions and a bonus Impaler
harpoon gun pre-order now far cry 4
available November 18 2014
you